Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, weißt du, was die Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch noch hätte verhindern können?
Die hundertsiebenunddreißigste Folge Lokbuchnetzpolitik.
Aber soweit lassen wir es leider gar nicht kommen, weil äh haben wir noch keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ist das schon mal ganz gut. Und Glück gehabt. Deswegen gibt's die hundertsiebenunddreißigste Folge von Lokbuchen Netzpolitik. Ja, wir sind's jetzt auch, wir sind es auch selbst, ja, also der Kanal wurde auch noch nicht übernommen,
Kann ja auch mal passieren, ja? Das äh weiß man ja nicht.
In den besten Senderfamilien vor.
Ja, trifft die härtesten Podcasts oder die Podcasts am härtesten.
Nee, nee, wir sind hier noch äh völlig aufrecht und äh immer noch mehrere Lichtjahre voneinander entfernt
Aber heute äh haben wir mal ganz ordentliche Qualität, könnte könnte durchaus eine interaktive Diskussion werden.
Ich will dir jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich so ein ganz leichtes Schnarzen in der Leitung habe.
Nee, das willst du mir jetzt nicht sagen.
Genau, weil sonst kriegst du wieder untern Schreibtisch und versuchst dann können wir die nächsten drei Wochen wieder nicht Podcasten, weil du irgendwie mit Clemenz am Telefon bist und irgendwie die die Goldkabel neu verlesst.
Nee, ich habe schon verstanden. Ich soll einfach das Maul halten und dich gewähren lassen.
Ich muss ja erstmal hier ähm.
Erstmal müssen wir ein bisschen, genau, wir müssen.
Richtig Stellung. Äh ein äh hier vornehmen, weil äh mir mehrere peinliche Fehler in der letzten Sendung unterlaufen sind,
Ähm der erste Fehler äh oder die erste Unklarheit, das war, glaube ich, das habe ich nicht falsch behauptet. Da habe ich nachher sogar zugegeben, dass ich nicht weiß, die zwanzig Prozent Regel steht im G zehn Gesetz.
Welche zwanzig Prozent Regel, soweit musst du das schon nochmal zusammenfassen? Wir haben ja auch neue Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Ähm da geht's also nämlich G zehn, wir erinnern uns ja, Grundgesetz, Artikel zehn, Einschränkungen des Brief, Post und Fernmeldegeheimnisses, da heißt es nämlich dann in Absatz vier,
in den Fällen der Paragraphen fünf und acht sind die Suchbegriffe in der Anordnung zu benennen, ferner sind das Gebiet über das Informationen gesammelt werden sollen und die Übertragungswege, die der Beschränkung unterliegen, zu bezeichnen.
Weiterhin ist festzulegen, welcher Anteil,
der auf diesen Übertragungswegen zur Verfügung stehenden Übertragungskapazität überwacht werden darf. In den Fällen des Paragraph fünf darf dieser Anteil höchstens zwanzig vom hundert betragen.
Das ist also genau diese zwanzig Prozent Regel, nur dass da nicht Prozent steht. Und ich glaube, dass ich ähm dachte,
als ich gesucht habe, weil ich hatte das, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, ähm sogar auf,
den Gesetzestext und äh habe da irgendwie drin gesucht, aber wahrscheinlich nach pro Cent oder nach dem Prozentzeichen und deswegen habe ich's dann nicht gefunden. Vielen Dank für den Hinweis an Tom.
Dann wird's nur noch peinlicher.
Entdeckt.
Wird's nur noch peinlicher,
denn ich habe in der letzten Folge in einer ausführlichen Erklärung, wo ich ja weiß, wo es langgeht, ähm das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium und die G zehn Kommission verwechselt.
Denn es war ähm die Rede davon, dass sich der Herr Landefeld vom Dezix,
aus freien Stücken an die G zehn Kommission gewendet hat und ich habe dann aber in der Folge von dem von die Aufgabenbeschreibung des parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums
für meine Argumentation zu Grunde gelegt.
Und äh um die beiden jetzt mal zu unterscheiden, denn darauf, also auch darauf wurden wir hingewiesen, sehr freundlich, das möchte ich ja hier auch kreditieren von ähm,
kreditieren. Kann man übrigens auch nicht sagen, ne? Das gibt's wahrscheinlich nicht. David. Äh David, hier ist dein Kredit. Ähm die G zehn Kommission.
Entscheidet von Amts wegen als unabhängiges Organ und es,
äh und als unabhängiges und an keine Weisung gebundenes Organ über die Notwendigkeit,
und Zulässigkeit sämtlicher durch die Nachrichtendienste des Bundes durchgeführten Beschränkungsmaßnahmen des Brief, Post und Fernmeldegeheimnis ist das Nachartikel zehn des Grundgesetzes. Das heißt, das sind diejenigen,
die ähm dann sagen, okay, das geht oder nicht. Also wenn ein Nachrichtendienst zum Beispiel ein Telefon abhören möchte, muss äh das äh schriftlich begründet äh beantragt werden. Beim,
Innenministerium, wenn das Innenministerium dem Antrag folgt,
geht das an die G zehn Kommission, ne? Also das Innenministerium ist nochmal dazwischen, damit die G zehn Kommission nicht nicht alle ähm Abhörabsichten bekommt, sondern eben auch nur die, wo das Innenministerium schon dann auch stattgegeben hat.
Ohne die Zustimmung der G zehn Kommission, darf die Überwachungsmaßnahme nicht durchgeführt werden,
Die G zehn Kommission besteht aus einem Vorsitzenden, der muss die Befähigung zum Richteramt haben, drei Beisitzern und vier Stellvertretern.
Und die werden vom Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium für die Dauer einer Wahlperiode bestellt,
Ja? Also das das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium bestellt, die G zehn Kommission für die Dauer einer Wahlperiode.
Und die müssen, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, keine Mitglieder des Bundestages sein, sonst wär's ja auch schwierig, weil so viele Richter gibt's ja gar nicht unter den Mitgliedern des Bundestages.
Ja, Juristen gibt's schon einige, aber vielleicht nicht so viele Richter, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ist die G zehn Kommission sehr viel mehr ähm, wie soll ich sagen, spezifisch,
auf die Fähigkeiten der Beurteilung hin ausgewählt als äh jetzt wie eine parlamentarische Kontrolle. Ich will mal Kommission sagen, weil früher hieß es ja, PKK müssen sie sich da mal umbenannt haben,
die ja im Wesentlichen, wie der Name schon sagt, parlamentarisch
definiert ist. Das heißt, hier sind halt die Parteien vertreten, des Parlaments und wenn die im Wesentlichen eine politische Kontrolle, sofern man davon überhaupt sprechen kann. Und die G zehn Kommission ist dann eben schon sehr viel mehr Expertenrunde in Anführungsstrichen.
Genau, um das noch kurz abzuschließen, die das parlamentarische Kontrollgänger, wenn ich jetzt schon mal das so schön gegoogelt habe, ob auf den Seiten des Bundestages, dass parlamentarische Kontrollgremium, das habe ich, glaube ich,
letzte Woche richtig beschrieben, kontrolliert die Bundesregierung hinsichtlich der Tätigkeit des der Nachrichtendienste des Bundes. Ähm,
Die Bundesregierung ist verpflichtet das äh Kontrollregion umfassend über die allgemeine Tätigkeit der Nachrichtendienste und über Vorgänge von besonderer Bedeutung zu unterrichten,
auf Verlangen des Gremiums hat sie auch über sonstige Vorgänge zu berichten. Das Gremium kann unter anderem Akten und Dateien der Nachrichtendienste einsehen, Befragungen von Angehörigen der Nachrichtendienste durchführen und hat Zutritt,
allen Dienststellen der Nachrichtendienste,
in Einzelfällen kann es mit der Mehrheit von zwei Drittel seiner Mitglieder einen Sachverständigen beauftragen zur Wahrnehmung seiner Kontrollaufgabenuntersuchung durchzuführen. An dieser Stelle sei auch nochmal darauf verwiesen, dass wir,
zur einhundertsten Folge, den Christian Ströbele besucht haben und in der Sendung zu Gast hatten,
in diesem Gremium lange Zeit tätig war und ich glaube aber sogar heute noch ist.
Genau, und äh ja, wie gesagt, Quelle deutscher Bundestag, insofern bin ich mir jetzt relativ sicher,
dass äh korrekt beschrieben zu haben. Für den Fall des Herrn stellt sich bleibt aber natürlich hier eine Unklarheit, denn der wurde ja vom BND angesprochen,
und so wie es aussieht,
wusste das, wusste die G zehn Kommission in dem Fall davon noch nicht, denn an die hatte sich der Landefeld ja dann gewandt und dafür dann im Kanzleramt sogar noch einen Rüffel bekommen. Und,
ähm wenn ich das jetzt hier richtig verstehe, dann war der BND oder war der BND der Ansicht,
im Rahmen seiner seines Herantretens an den Herrn Landefeld noch so in den Sondierungsgesprächen zu sein
und noch gar nicht das äh die die G zehn Kommission über seine
Herangehensweise dort in Kenntnis gesetzt haben zu müssen und deswegen war das wahrscheinlich dann überraschend, als der Herr Landefeld dann bei der G zehn Kommission angerufen hat und gesagt hat, ey hier war gerade, hier waren gerade so ein paar komische
vom BND, was ist denn da los? Ja. So,
da sind also hoffentlich alle Unklarheiten beseitigt. Dann haben wir ja noch Tim, ganz viel Feedback zur letzten Sendung bekommen, was äh aber ähm.
Was jetzt gar nicht unbedingt so in Fehlerkorrekturen äh unbedingt zusammenzufassen ist. Denn wir haben zu unserem kleinen,
etwas verlängerten Prolog ähm zur zum zehnjährigen Bestehen von Fefes Block gemischtes Feedback bekommen. Einmal ähm,
wurde uns vorgeworfen, wir hätten Fefe ungebührend verteidigt und in Schutz genommen, obwohl er doch so so oft über die Schräge tritt,
strenge tritt und ähm andere haben sich dann darüber beschwert, dass wir Fefa angegriffen hätten. Ja, da wurde ging also auch dann Anzeigen ein,
ähm.
Anzeigen. Wo ging die einen? Aha.
Und äh ach so und das dritte Feedback war, wer ist Schäfer? Fand ich auch schön. Aber äh was ich ganz spannend fand, ist.
Oder ohne mich da groß äh drüber lustig machen zu wollen. Also das muss auch irgendwie klar sein, ne. Wir haben das so ein bisschen mit so einer Selbstverständlichkeit äh ähm
so wiedergegeben als als müsste jetzt irgendwie allen Leuten klar sein, äh um welche Personen oder Publikationssysteme es jetzt hier geht,
vollkommen nachvollziehbar, dass das nicht für jeden vollkommen nachvollziehbar ist, so, ne?
Ja, ich ich hoffe, dass vielleicht trotzdem noch genug da damit dran war, dass man vielleicht auch so verstanden hat, ohne ohne jetzt genau zu wissen, worum's geht, aber klar. Ähm,
Aber was ich ganz interessant finde, wenn wir so aus beiden Seiten den den und den,
es scheint in der Mitte nicht viel zu geben. Äh wenn wir von beiden jetzt so Flak bekommen, dann gibt's eigentlich zwei Möglichkeiten. Erstens, wir haben uns ähm.
Fundamental, unklar ausgedrückt und äh oder zweitens, wir haben endlich mal ausgewogen über ein Thema berichtet, ja? Ähm,
Aber ich glaube, es ist eher das Erstere, denn ähm,
Eigentlich war, wollte ich damit so ein bisschen die Botschaft rüberbringen, dass egal in welche äh Richtung ihr euch aufregt, ihr wahrscheinlich ähm,
selbst keinen Gefallen tut und das war eher so der Kern der Botschaft, denn es gibt immer einen, der provoziert,
und einen, der sich provozieren lässt und das wird euch euer Leben lang verfolgen, nicht nur im Internet,
Da draußen marodieren Armeen von Arschlöchern, das werdet ihr nicht ändern können. Was ihr aber ändern könnt ist, wie es euch damit geht und ob ihr euch darauf einlasst oder nicht.
Und deswegen war das ein Appell, dass wir uns alle diese Hasskultur sparen, unsere Kräfte schonen, nach vorne blicken, Schönes schaffen,
und uns auf die großen und wichtigen Gegner konzentrieren, die sich ins Fäuschen lachen, wenn wir unsere Grabenkämpfe führen. Denn solange wir das machen, wird's nichts mit der Revolution.
Ja, ignorieren ist manchmal einfach auch wirklich äh allein vom Energiehaushalt schon sehr äh sehr sinnvoll so, weil es bringt halt äh doch selten, was ich da,
sich aufzureiben im Netz und ähm ich beobachte das auch manchmal ein bisschen mit Trauer, wie sehr manche Leute sich da aufreiben
also bis also wirklich auch so bis bis zur physikalischen Erschöpfung, ja, also mental, physikalische Erschöpfung.
Und man fragt sich halt immer so ein bisschen, wie wie kann man das eigentlich so so ernst nehmen? Also nicht, nicht das, was jetzt alles lächerlich sei oder dass dass der Netzdiskurs irgendwie äh nichts taugt oder so,
soweit würde ich niemals gehen wollen, weil ich, ich schätze den Diskurs und ich denke, dass der auch eine ganze Menge äh bringen kann, aber man muss halt auch sehen,
dass das bestenfalls so fünfzig Prozent zur Meinungsbildung beitragen darf und dass da also sowohl Trends
die sich vermeintlich dort abzeichnen, ja, die im Wesentlichen ja auch ein bisschen was mit der eigenen Bubble zu tun haben, was beobachte ich eigentlich im Netz, was sehe ich, was ist meine Timeline?
Und ähm das kann,
kann irgendwie andeuten, dass es irgendein Trend gibt, aber man muss auf jeden Fall da auch nochmal seine seinen eigenen Rat und sein eigenes äh Verständnis befragen und vielleicht auch einfach nochmal eine Nacht drüber schlafen, bevor man auf irgendwas reagiert.
Hilft.
Ja, dieser ähm,
wahrscheinlich weiseste Cartoon äh den man zu diesem Thema im Internet finden kann, ist der, ich weiß nicht genau, die Zahl, aber der Titel ist.
Mhm.
Oft zitiert und ähm also ein ein absolutes Meisterwerk. Wir werden den mal äh glaube ich bei uns in den Shownotes auch einbetten, nicht wahr, Tim.
Ja, das ist äh auf jeden Fall angemessen. Den kann man nicht oft genug lesen. Ist auch nur ein Bild. Äh ist alles drin, was man über das Internet wissen muss.
Absolut. Ähm dann haben wir noch eine äh Beschwerde auch zu dem Thema bekommen und zwar von Michael Seemann. Der hat sich zu Recht beschwert,
ähm dass wir uns nämlich auf einen Text von ihm unter anderem bezogen haben, ohne ihn zu erwähnen und dann ist dummerweise auch noch passiert, dass es nicht in den gelandet ist, weil wir einfach keine Shownotes zu dem Thema hatten, weil's spontan kam,
Dafür bitte ich an dieser Stelle um Entschuldigung, das war keine böse Absicht,
und ähm um das noch kurz sicherzustellen, dass äh wessen Kernthesen von wem sind und welche nicht von Michael Seemann sind
den wir dann auch noch verlinkt haben, nachdem er sich beschwert hat, hier nochmal die Kernthesen,
seiner Einlassung, wie gesagt, neben vielen anderen, die meisten wurden bei selber veröffentlicht, aber Michael Seemann hat die auf seinem Blog veröffentlicht, das ist das Blog MS Pro DE und seine Kernthesen lauteten,
Hat keine Ahnung und recherchiert auch nicht, um das zu ändern? Fefe ist ignorant und reaktionär. Fefe ist ein Arschloch.
Fefe ist ein Pfiffist. Andere Standpunkte, die wir angesprochen haben, sind aber ausdrücklich nicht Michael Seemann, zuzurechnen.
Dafür habe ich aber Michael Seemann in der letzten Sendung für einen Tweet gelobt,
Der stammt aber gar nicht von ihm, sondern von Roman Held, alias at hoch einundzwanzig und der hat zweitausenddreizehn äh mit dem Twittern aufgehört, was äh glaube ich ein äh herber Verlust für,
ähm.
Das Internet ist, dass da.
Eher für die Fluffigkeit der der Herangehensweisen an an viele Themen und Sachverhalte ist. Lustiger Vogel.
Irgendjemand meint der wäre aber auf Facebook. Habe ich aber jetzt nicht kontrolliert. Kann auch wieder falsch sein.
Bestimmt fake gekraut.
So, wie viel Minuten, wie viele Minuten richtig Stellung haben wir jetzt?
Äh weiß ich nicht, ausreichend.
Okay. Ähm dann können wir jetzt mal zu den Themen kommen, oder? Ähm.
Ein französischer Fernsehsender wurde äh auf und ausgemacht. TV fünf T äh oder wie haben Französisch ist ja schon so eine schwierige Sprache, ne.
Song heißt das. TV.
Hm
Ähm.
Und zwar das ist echt, also in der Nacht zum Donnerstag, heute ist Donnerstag, also letzte Nacht. Ähm vielen mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig alle elf Kanäle des Senders aus.
Und waren drei Stunden offline und danach haben sie ihren Ding auch noch nicht so wieder ganz im Griff gehabt und erstmal nur Wiederholungen da irgendwie durchgesendet und das Internet-Angebot ist bis jetzt noch nicht wieder vollständig da.
Auf der Webseite und auf deren Facebook-Seite waren dann kurzfristig,
islamistische Drohungen äh veröffentlicht worden. Ähm und irgendwie ähm persönliche Daten von Soldaten und Kopien derer Ausweise,
und Propaganda-Videos in französischer, arabischer und englischer Sprache.
Und das heißt, es wurden also gleichzeitig die internen IT-Systeme und die Sendeanlagen,
und die Website und Twitter und Facebook aufgemacht. Das heißt, so ungefähr alles, was die hatten.
Wurde in einem in einem Schlag übernommen und ähm ja, für,
eine für das für die Verbreitung von Propaganda, aber natürlich auch in dem Fall für eine wirklich enorme Machtdemonstration genutzt.
Und ich bin ja eigentlich immer so ähm,
Wenn ich mir anschaue, was was so was man alles hört von Cyber-Terrorismus und was ja jetzt alles irgendwie in Zukunft passieren wird und so äh halte ich das ja alles immer für ein bisschen.
Betrachte ich das ja noch so ein bisschen mit einem zweifelnden Auge, weil ich das nicht so nicht so ganz sehe bisher,
Aber äh so ein TV-Sender, zentralen TV-Sender zu übernehmen, ist natürlich schon echt mal,
was was als Angriff gewertet werden kann oder wie siehst du das?
Ja, also ich meine, vor allem die Tatsache, dass jetzt hier so vollkommen unterschiedliche Dienste alle auf einmal übernommen wurden. Zeigen ja schon, dass das hier kein Zufallswerk ist.
Ja, also gut, sind auch gut vorbereitet gewesen und in dem Moment, wo sie dann selber noch Material posten, das Zeug natürlich ohnehin schon für eine gewisse Vorbereitung, aber äh man hätte ja auch sagen können, okay, da halten sie irgendwo eine Sicherheitslücke
und die, da haben sie dann, nachdem sie das entdeckt haben, beschlossen, das mal dafür zu nutzen, das ist ja so der typische eigentlich, ne?
Ähm aber äh die Tatsache, dass jetzt hier binnen so kurzer Zeit gleich so viele Systeme übernommen wurden, also die ja alle unterschiedlicher Natur sind, auch wenn sie irgendwie alle in irgendeiner Form mit
mit Netz und Technik und und Öffentlichkeit zu tun haben, zeugt doch schon von einer extrem vorbereiteten konzertierten äh wohlgeplanten
Aktion und soll wohl auch davon künden,
Ja und das ist ja so ein bisschen so äh Flashback aus so Science-Fiction der, weiß ich nicht, siebziger Jahre oder so
Hatten wir so noch nicht, oder?
Ich glaube nicht, ein ein TV-Sender.
Kann ich mich noch nicht dran erinnern, aber so als Vision so. Man klingt sich da ein und so weiter, äh keine Ahnung. Das habe ich schon in Mickey Mouse gelesen, also das das ist schon so ein so ein so ein Bild, was man immer hat.
Es gab mal in den USA ein ähm ein Hack vor ein paar Jahren. Da ging es um das Emergency Warnsystem
Also es gibt es gibt quasi wenn ich das Recht entsinne so,
System, wo im Prinzip die Regierung oder berechtigte Stellen einfach sofort reinschreiben können, hier ähm Unwetterwarnung oder was, ne, oder oder also jetzt nicht oder,
Terror, Atom, der Russe kommt oder also was halt, ne, an an,
Bedrohungsszenarien irgendwie da sein kann und das läuft dann halt sofort ungefragt bei allen TV-Sendern sofort äh durchs Bild.
Wenn du also jetzt wirklich ganz schnell weg muss äh in Sicherheit muss oder so, dafür ist das gedacht und das hatte vor ein paar Jahren mal
irgendwo in den USA. Ich glaube, dass ich weiß, aber das war auch nicht bundesweit, sondern nur in so einem Bundesstaat, glaube ich, mal irgendwie enormes übernommen und haben dann da äh irgendwie irgendwelche Scherze reingeschrieben. Wenn wenn ich mich jetzt recht entsinne,
Aber die wirklich so ein so eine Komplettübernahme gab's zuletzt bei Sony, ne?
Also ich mein Sony äh war äh also Pictures Entertainment, ne? Das war ja nicht ganz sonnig, sondern nur nur die. Äh die haben aber ja, glaube ich, nur Fernseher und nee, haben sie ja nicht äh und,
nur Kinos, die die die senden ja quasi in Kinos und das äh die waren da jetzt nicht von betroffen.
Die senden eigentlich gar nicht. Also das ist ja, glaube ich, der Unterschied, dass man's hier jetzt wirklich mal mit einem Fernsehsender im Sinne von News, online vierundzwanzig Stunden äh zu tun hat und Sony Pictures war ja im Prinzip nur eine Firma, die,
Dinge produziert und verkauft.
Also das ist schon harte, das ist schon ein harter Shit. Ähm,
Vor allem weiß ich auch nicht, wie die Franzosen darauf jetzt reagieren. Die haben ja erst vor Kurzem eine sehr ähm leidvolle Erfahrung ähm gemacht im,
mit mit den ähm mit den Angriffen auf die Satire äh Redaktion. Charlie Epdo.
Und wenn denn jetzt auch noch irgendwie so eine so eine sehr, sehr einschüchternde Maßnahme.
Dazu teil wird. Äh es ist äh schon ähm.
Eine hoffentlich eine Büchse, die wieder zugeht und jetzt nicht so eine Pandora-Büchse ist. Weil ich, ehrlich gesagt, ähm.
Ohne da jetzt genaue Kenntnis von zu haben, da wahrscheinlich den größeren Teil der der ähm der Fernsehsender grundsätzlich erstmal für sehr verwohnbar halte in diesem Bereich.
Mir auch gut vorstellen.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass man wirklich bis an die an diese Senderanlagen kommt.
Da hätte ich schon irgendwie nochmal ein bisschen mehr erwartet. Andererseits ist das mit ein paar Gedanken dann auch nicht mehr so überraschend, weil,
äh die natürlich da irgendwie auch mit Computersystemen arbeiten und die selbstverständlich nicht äh von ihren lokalen Netzen trennen, sondern selbstverständlich sind die vernetzt bis unter,
bis unters Dach, ja. Insofern.
Ja, ich denke, das ist wahrscheinlich auch einfach eine Folge der der zunehmenden Vernetzisierung. Also, dass das einfach alles auf IP umgestellt wird und dass die ganzen Workshops auch übers Netz koordiniert werden und äh da verfängt sich das. Ich meine, es gab
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen anders gelagert, aber es gab ja mal dieses schöne äh Projekt, wo diese Satelliten ablenkst,
diese Fernsehsoliten ab links mitgeschnitten wurden, weil die halt auch einfach unverschlüsselt natürlich,
über, über den Kanal ging. Äh weiß nicht, ob sie sich daran erinnerst, mit so so großartigen Szenen, die dann so äh,
George, passt George Bush, ich glaube George Busch sich irgendwie mit ähm hier ist noch gleich dieser Talker ähm.
Wahrscheinlich.
Nee, Larry King irgendwie.
Ach so.
Ja, über über Medikamente unterhalten haben, an was er denn so nimmt und so weiter, ne. Also,
die letzten Minuten bevor sie on air gehen, ja? Und dann sitzen sie da halt alle Mikrofone an und verstehen gar nicht, dass das sozusagen über das gesamte äh US-amerikanische Gebiet ausgestrahlt wird
Da hat halt einfach mal jemand mitgeschnitten und diese ganzen schönen Stielblüten dann irgendwann mal so einen so einen Film zusammengepackt. Mal gucken, vielleicht finde ich den Link noch, das äh großartiges Ding, aber auch das zeigte, das ist halt einfach so eine Infrastruktur, über die man sich bisher noch keine Gedanken gemacht hat. Und ich,
will den gar nicht unterstellen, dass sie sich darüber gar keine Gedanken gemacht haben, aber
Offensichtlich haben sie sich nicht genug Gedanken dazu gemacht und auch sehr offensichtlich werden sich in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten wahrscheinlich eine ganze Menge Fernsehsender äh Gedanken machen müssen,
allein schon, weil hier natürlich das Establishment richtig was zu befürchten,
das ist für sie äh etwas, was sie ja mal gerne unter Kontrolle halten möchten und wenn jetzt einfach irgendein jeder dahergelaufene Standardterrorist äh hier seine Botschaften verbreiten kann, da sieht
nicht gut aus.
Da, das stimmt, aber machst du, ist für dich die größere Sorge, ähm dass sie da Botschaften verbreitet haben oder ist für dich die größere Sorge, dass sie da mit den Menschen Angst eingejagt haben?
Ich habe nicht gedacht, dass ich mir Sorgen mache. Ich habe nur gesagt, das Establishment macht sich Sorgen, weil sowas natürlich auch nachhaltig äh dem ähm Mantra, es ist alles okay, es ist alles unter Kontrolle. Stark zuwiderläuft.
Ja, ja, genau, aber da, ja, also, genau, es geht, glaube ich, weniger um die Botschaften als zu zeigen, ey,
Ich meine, auf eins ist äh ist im Westen echt Verlass, so der Fernseher funktioniert so. Da kannst du mal von ausgehen,
und da gibt's ja auch äh viele Cartoons und und Zeichentrickfilme drüber, die da irgendwie so behandeln, was passiert, wenn der Fernseher,
ausfällt, ne? Ich glaube, das war noch so, so da war das mit dem Internet noch nicht so so in. Ähm da habe ich einen sehr schönen Kurzfilm gesehen, der mir gute Erinnerungen geblieben ist, wo dann so,
relativ langsam so gezeichnet, okay, Fernseher fällt aus, ne, und dann sind die Leute erstmal so ein Stündchen sind die halt,
gelangweilt, dann werden sie irgendwann nervös und das endet halt natürlich in so einem ganz fürchterlichen Weltkrieg, ne, weil die weil die Leute vom,
irgendwie ihr ihren Fernseher nicht mehr haben. Ähm das war natürlich so ein bisschen ironisch und so und ähm,
wir kriegen jetzt nicht einen Weltkrieg, nur weil der Fernseher ausfällt, aber das ist halt etwas, worauf sich die Leute sehr ähm,
sehr verlassen. Und ich glaube, man ein Strom Strom fällt mal aus, dann geht auch der Fernseher aus.
Aber so wirklich Fernseher ist halt eigentlich schon immer noch da. Man weiß, der Fernseher würde das eigentlich noch empfangen, ne? Wenn, wenn man Strom hätte,
Kann man ja auch teilweise kann man sich ja dann auch eine unabhängige äh Stromversorgung noch da an den Fernseher anschließen, wenn man da sehr drauf angewiesen ist.
Ja, stell mal vor, alle, alle Broadcast-Medien würden wirklich morgen aus sein. Egal, welchen Kanal du ansetzt,
es kommt einfach nur noch Testbild oder weißes Rauschen. Radio anschalten nichts.
Keine Botschaften von außen. Gut, jetzt haben wir noch Internet, so, das müsste dann auch schon komplett weg sein. Insofern, denke ich mal, hat das Internet äh an der Stelle auch schon.
Wahrscheinlich auch schon längst übernommen,
was so die Realitätsdefinition betrifft. Ja, aber wenn dann, sagen wir mal, die passenden Webseiten zu diesen Kanälen, die du normalerweise erwartest, dann auch nicht da sind. Und äh man nur noch auf Twitter freidreht, dann wird's äh richtig sportlich.
Ich also was ich glaube, was jetzt passieren wird, ist, jetzt werden sich die ganzen Cyber-Experten melden,
Äh und und jetzt irgendwie erzählen, ne? Weil ja dann wenn der Fernseher ist ja dann doch immer noch kennst ja dann auch immer in diesen in diesen.
Eigentlich nicht nur in in irgendwelchen Science Fiction äh äh Apokalypse Film, sondern auch in in historischen Filmen und auch in der Geschichte war's ja dann so, weißt du, dass die Leute dann da
äh
wenn wenn halt irgendwie der Strom weg ist und so, dann sitzt er halt mit deinem Batterieradio da und äh ne, wenn der wenn die, wenn der nuklear Angriff dann kommt oder so und so eine.
Solche Sendeanlagen zu übernehmen ist echt ein übles Signal, weil du oder das echt eine eine sehr, sehr krasse Machtdemonstration. Also.
Auch bei so einem Putsch-Versuchen hast du ja eigentlich auch immer so der Angriff auf das Haupt-Fernsehstudio,
der ist dann immer auch sehr wichtig. Und wenn so äh die Putschisten das übernommen haben und darüber ihre Botschaften senden können mit es ist jetzt einfach alles anders, dann ist das sozusagen dann der auch der definierende Moment.
Meinst du, wie die griechische Regierung letztes Jahr? Als sie den Fernseher abgeschaltet haben.
Ist eher anders.
Die haben doch noch die öffentlich rechtlichen da rausgestürmt, ne. Okay, aber ich weiß, das war jetzt ein bisschen was.
Naja, ist auf jeden Fall alles äh ja, ready, ready for Cyber äh Attack des denke ich auch, das wird jetzt.
Wird jetzt nochmal viel, viel ähm viel gecybert werden.
Auf jeden Fall.
Werde übrigens auch äh kann ich äh warum ich da jetzt auch äh also ich merke, dass ich über das Thema gerade mehr nachdenken
nachdenke und wahrscheinlich auch hier reden will, als vielleicht normal ist, weil ich mich gerade mit der äh mit meiner Stellungnahme zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz auseinandersetze. Ähm die schreibe ich so nebenbei immer abends.
Ja, wann äh wann musst du die machen? Dann musst du die äußern.
Am an Führers Geburtstag, muss ich in den, am zwanzigsten April muss ich in den Innenausschuss des Deutschen Bundestags,
glaube ich ein Montag oder ein Dienstag. Auf jeden Fall kein Freitag. Sonst hätte ich das nicht gemacht
Nein, Quatsch. Ähm zwanzigster, zwanzigster April ist dann, genau, das ist Montag, der zwanzigste April, vierzehn Uhr im im Innenausschuss, da ähm
bin ich als Sachverständiger geladen und deswegen lese ich gerade IT-Sicherheitsgesetz und denke halt natürlich viel über so Angriffsszenarien nach und so und,
also ich glaube da geht's ja viel um kritische Infrastruktur. Ähm da zählen diese Fernsehsender glaube ich gar nicht unbedingt runter.
Aber äh trotzdem gerade so ein bisschen drüber am Nachdenken über das Thema. Aber was mir ähm dann noch einfällt, Tim,
in dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz geht's nämlich hauptsächlich um um kritische Infrastruktur. Und was eigentlich fehlt, sind ähm,
Also um jetzt da irgendwie sich großartig Sorgen zu machen, sind eigentlich diese Angriffe. Also das Einzige, was das Einzige, was das BSI irgendwie für zweitausendvierzehn vermeldet hat, ist es, dass es irgendwie so ein,
sehr guten Fishing-Angriff auf ein paar Mitarbeiter äh bei einem Energieversorger, glaube ich, gab oder irgendwas, irgendwas irgendwas kritische Infrastruktur und den wurden dann die Kontodaten abgefischt, also ähm,
hält sich das jetzt erstmal noch so in,
in Grenzen mit dem ganzen Cyberkrieg, aber ähm Fernseh äh Anstalten angreifen und Angst und Schrecken zu verbreiten, ist jetzt erstmal, was weiß ich, ähm.
Was mich beunruhigt in dem Bereich. Also ich äh finde das erstmal nicht so gut.
Ja, vor allem, wir wissen ja auch immer, immer, wenn's dann auch so ganz offensichtlich wieder mit Terror zusammenhängt. Weil man könnte jetzt auch genauso argumentieren, ist ja eigentlich nichts passiert.
Ich meine, okay, da haben jetzt mal ein paar Leute Videos, die es sowieso überall im Internet gibt, auf so einem Kanal rausgeblasen.
Ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass irgendwas umgefallen ist oder irgendjemand gestorben ist oder irgendwas, was was wirklich nachhaltig unser Leben beeinflusst. Trotz alledem ist es natürlich äh medial,
Aufbauspar bis äh zum Getnor und natürlich auch politisch aufbauspar bis zum Getner und das wird dann wahrscheinlich auch genauso passieren.
Medial aber nur, solange man auch Fernsehsender haben.
Ja, ich glaube, die werden wir noch länger haben, als uns lieb ist.
Ja, leider. Okay, kommen wir zum, kommen wir zum nächsten Thema. Wir bleiben bei bei Fernsehsendern und Dingen, die, wenn sie ausfallen, die Menschen beunruhigen Facebook.
Habe ich doch wahrscheinlich hier schon mal öfter erzählt, ne, wo ähm wo Facebook war doch mal vor ein paar Wochen,
oder ist das schon wieder ein paar Monate her, die waren mal irgendwie eine Stunde oder zwei down in größeren Teilen der Welt?
Und ähm das hat den ganzen Prepaid-Kartenbetreibern eine Menge Geld eingebracht, weil die Leute alle ihre Handys wieder aufgeladen haben, weil die dachten, ihr Datenvolumen wäre aufgebraucht.
Ist auch schön.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, wir machen hier Internet und Facebook ist und das zieht direkt dran vorbei.
Ja, die Facebook-Realität, die ist schon wirklich obscore. Äh du erinnerst dich sicherlich auch noch an diesen großartigen Fall, wo es mal so einen populären Artikel äh zum Thema Lookin-Probleme bei bei Facebook,
ging, du erinnerst dich. Und der war dann, der war dann so beliebt, dass wenn man nach Facebook Login bei Google suchte,
auf diesen Artikel kam und dann füllte sich die Kommentarbereich dieses Artikels mit verzweifelten Leuten, die äh auf Facebook einredet und sie sollen doch bitte die Seite wieder so machen, wie sie früher war, sie würden das Feld nicht finden, um sich anzumelden.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Doch, das ist sehr mein Ernst, ja, weil äh Leute einfach geben in ihrer Suchmaschine einfach Facebook-Login ein,
klicken auf den ersten Link und das ist halt normalerweise,
Facebook und da an dem Tag warst du äh halt mal nicht so und die haben sich alle furchtbar aufgeregt und was ihnen denn einfallen würde und so geht's ja nun gar nicht und ja, also.
Okay, das ist aber lange her sein, weil alles, was ich zu Facebook-Login finde, alles, also alles. Die ersten zehn Google-Triff, also sind äh sind, sind Facebook.
Zwei Jahre, zwei, drei Jahre her.
Okay. Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Die haben natürlich dann auch diesen Artikel irgendwie runter gerankt um wieder Schlimmeres zu verhindern, weil einfach die die Meute einfach überhaupt nicht mehr steuerbar war. Einfach ist ganz schlimm.
Okay, also wenn wir, wenn wir von Facebook reden, grade dann äh reden wir von ähm natürlich von der Initiative von Max Shrems. Ich habe das ähm,
vor ein, zwei Wochen schon mal angesprochen. Max Shrems, ein Österreicher, der ja schon vor einiger Zeit mit der Initiative versus Facebook äh immer wieder kleine Teilerfolge in,
datenschutzrechtlichen,
Auseinandersetzungen mit Facebook gefeiert hat. Unter anderem eben, dass er damals sein, ein Dampf seiner Daten äh mundgerecht als als siebenhundertseitiges PDF oder so bekommen hat und ähm,
dass er regelmäßig denen irgendwie ein ein Dornen im im Fleisch ist. Und er hat ähm auch da jetzt schon ein Buch drüber geschrieben über seine ähm über seine Behandlung dieses Themas und.
Er hat sich immer eigentlich in Irland beschwert, also am Unternehmenssitz und in seiner neuen,
Beschwerde, wo er sehr, sehr viele äh Verstöße gegen das äh österreichische und das das europäische Datenschutzrecht ähm,
behandelt. Ähm klagt er jetzt in Wien? Und zwar ähm ist ihm das möglich,
wenn er dies als Verbraucher tut. Also die,
wenn du Verbraucher bist, dann hast du das Recht ähm darauf,
das Verfahren in deiner Heimat anzustreben, dann kannst du also gegen Facebook, was da irgendwo in in Irland operiert, aber in Deutschland Dienste anbietet, ähm,
Kannst du oder er ist, sorry, in Österreich natürlich, in Österreich Dienste anbietet, ähm dann kannst du ähm,
entsprechend in Österreich dich auch da äh da beschweren, um deine Rechte geltend zu machen.
Dass es jetzt österreichische Gesetzgebung, nicht europäische Gesetzgebung.
Ich und jetzt kommt nämlich genau der Grund, warum ich dem Max gerade eine E-Mail geschrieben habe, dass wir ihn wirklich unbedingt nächste Woche in der Sendung brauchen,
er ist eben, also er ist ja Jurastudent, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ist noch nicht fertig mit dem Studium. Ähm.
Und genau diese Sachen weiß ich alle nicht so genau, aber im Moment ist es auf jeden Fall so, dass vor dem,
Wiener Gericht, in dem er das ist. Und das ist ja jetzt so die erste Instanz und er geht eh davon aus, dass dieses Gericht den Fall abgibt wegen Nichtzuständigkeit. Aber man muss ja immer man muss sich ja quasi hochklagen.
Und ähm es sei denn, du hast von vorneherein irgendwie so eine riesige Bedeutung, dass du,
an an höheres Gericht ist, aber er fängt jetzt erstmal schön an seinem Gerichtsstand an, da ist in in Wien da hingegangen und jetzt wird erstmal debattiert, ob das Gericht die Klage überhaupt annimmt,
also die Frage der Zuständigkeit und Zulässigkeit der Klage. Und interessanterweise ähm.
Geht Facebook eben den Weg zu sagen, ey,
Ist ja gar kein Verbraucher. Das ist doch ein Aktivist, der schreibt Bücher über uns, ist gefragter Gast in Diskussionsveranstaltungen und verfolgt mit dieser Klage,
einem eigenen beruflichen, unternehmerischen Interesse. Nun hat er,
weltweit haben fünfundzwanzigtausend Menschen ihre Interessen schon an ihn abgegeben.
Sind aber jetzt gehören also noch nicht offiziell zu den Klägern, aber haben schon angekündigt, dass sie ihre Interessen
innerhalb dieser Klage vertreten lassen wollen und fünfzig weitere Facebook äh Facebook Nutzer hat er ähm laut eigenen Angaben auf einer entsprechenden Warteliste. Das heißt, da wird jetzt so eine,
Massengeschichte draus. Und das ist natürlich interessant eigentlich, dass er ähm dass Facebook,
ihn jetzt an der Flanke äh versucht anzugreifen. Fand ich, also klar, Facebooksanwälte werden natürlich alles machen, was sie können, um das Ding irgendwie äh zurückzutreiben. Ähm,
Die scheinen ja sowieso so ein bisschen der Ansicht zu sein, wenn du, wenn er das jetzt in Irland eingereicht hätte, dann hätten die gesagt, bis zum falschen Land, du wohnst in Österreich und wenn das in Österreich einreicht, dann dann sagen sie natürlich, ey,
äh äh bist gar kein Verbraucher, du bist Aktivist, ist klar. Anwälte sind dafür da, um einen irgendwie aus aus so Sachen rauszuhauen und dafür hat Facebook eben auch ganz viele davon.
Jo. Ja, ich bin gespannt, wie das äh weitergeht. Das war, glaube ich, der erste Verhandlungstag äh ist jetzt gewesen.
Jedem. Ich, der ist entweder heute oder morgen oder so. Also, das ist jetzt, es ist jetzt so. Und ich find's auf jeden Fall interessant.
Ist ist, es war eine eine Tatsachenfeststellung Linus.
Kann ich nicht machen, ne? Ähm eine Tatsachen feststellen, kann ich nicht machen oder was?
Nein, ich sage nur, der erste Verhandlungstag ist gelaufen. Das berichtet die Group versus Facebook Webseite von dem Max Shrimps selber und deswegen gehe ich mal davon aus, dass dem auch so ist.
Ah Mist. Die machen hier, weißt du, die machen während der Sendung weiter. Weil das ist ja, das ist ja heute. Äh.
Auch wirklich äh manchmal das Gefühl, während wir die Sendung machen, bleibt die Zeit draußen nicht stehen.
Könnt ihr euch nicht mal ein bisschen danach richten. Ähm,
in der Pressemitteilung sagt, die Verhandlung ist aus meiner Sicht super gelaufen. Wir konnten aus unserer Sicht alle Argumente von Facebook entkräften und warten jetzt mit Spannung auf die Entscheidung der Richterin und das Landgericht Wien.
Vor dem heute diese Verhandlung stattgefunden hat, hat noch sechs Wochen Zeit. Ähm oder hat,
hat's noch sechs, sechs Wochen Zeit gegeben, um weiter Urkunden zu übersetzen und wird dann eine äh Entscheidung, über die Zulässigkeit der Klage in Wien äh schriftlich äh fällen.
Kommentar Max, man braucht halt einen langen Atem.
Der den hat er, den hat er, ey, also.
Den hat er auf jeden Fall. Na ja, auf jeden Fall alt ist nicht sonderlich, wenn er nächste Woche keine Zeit hat dann.
Nix, der muss jetzt, wir haben so oft schon über den geredet, jetzt muss er das mal hier auch erklären, ich verstehe das ja auch alles gar nicht da, was er da macht.
Inhaltlich. Ich verstehe auch nicht so ganz, warum er das macht, weil ich würde einfach, ich würde dann einfach Facebook nicht nutzen und ich nutze das ja auch nicht,
außer natürlich für die Facebook Logbook Netzpolitik Seite die ich an dieser Stelle nochmal promoten möchte, liked uns,
und ansonsten benutze ich kein Facebook, aber irgendjemand muss es tun und ähm ich habe vor ein paar Wochen auch bei einem,
Verbraucherschutzevent.
Mal darauf hingewiesen, dass man da ja irgendwie relativ wenig sieht, ja? Also ich meine, dass das, was mir irgendwie noch in Erinnerung bleibt, ist wie äh wie wie äh Ilse Eigner, ähm es Facebook richtig gezeigt hat.
Als die Verbraucherschutzministerin, die eine Person in in Deutschland, die irgendwas gegen Facebook unternehmen könnte, wenn Facebook gegen geltendes Recht verstößt,
die jetzt sich abgemeldet, weil die sich nicht an den Datenschutz halten. Das war also ein, das war ungefähr das peinlichste äh was ich, was ich je gesehen habe und da ist der Max mir um einiges lieber.
Ja, aber das hat natürlich eine Schockwelle gesendet, ne, durch äh durch Facebook. Also.
Die haben richtig gelitten.
Die ging mindestens, also ich würde sagen, die Schockwelle von ihrer Abmeldung, die ging mindestens über drei oder vier äh Netzwerkswitches und dann,
ja, war's wahrscheinlich auch schon vorbei. Zumindest kann sie nicht mehr als Konsument denn äh klagen, weil sie konsumiert das ja nicht.
Weißt du, was das genau? Jetzt kann sie die wollte sie nur aus der Affäre ziehen. Und ähm was wir gerade was wir als ich das äh letzte oder vorletzte Woche, da war recherchiert habe, die ist jetzt wieder auf Facebook.
Nein.
Ja, aber pass auf, pass auf. Mich mit einer eigenen Seite.
Sondern.
Sondern ähm Facebook ähm Personen aus der Wikipedia,
und er stellt den dann so Facebookseiten als Interesse. Also ähm man kann auf Facebook ein Interesse sein.
Ja und rate mal, wer auch eins ist, weil äh Wikipedia.
Da kannst du mal davon ausgehen, dass es da den Tim und den Linus auch gibt. Ja, ich habe, ich habe, glaube ich, mal, warte mal, ich muss mal gucken.
Person des öffentlichen Lebens. Das ist nicht meine.
Das haben wir, das haben wir davon, dass wir irgendwie hier schön so eine äh so eine Wikipedia unterstützen, wo alle, wo alle Inhalte in CC-Lizenz sind.
Und dann als Dankeschön uns dann da aus dem aus dem Wikipedia raus und macht uns da gegen unseren Willen äh zerrt das uns in in ihre komische Dingens da rein.
Warte mal, ich habe mal, ich gucke mal hier eben.
Guck mal, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Äh Personen oder Seiten.
Also mal. Okay. Dachte, genau. Ich bin ihr Linus Neumann ist ein Interesse. Ich bin ein Interesse. Ich bin jetzt keine, ich bin nicht als Person da, sondern als Interesse.
Du bist ein Interesse. Ich bin Person des öffentlichen Lebens.
Ich weiß nicht, ich vielleicht bist du eine Person des öffentlichen Lebens, ich bin nur ein Interesse.
Ja, aber du stehst da.
Du hast eine du bist du bist ja sogar da. Du, dich habe ich jetzt hier. Okay, sorry, ich verstehe das mit diesem Facebook nicht. Ich bin da auch.
Ja, ich habe, ich habe, ich habe da einen Account, ja? Ich habe da einen Account, wie ich auf nahezu allen äh Netzwerken, die irgendwo mal Erwähnungen gefunden haben, einen Account habe, um das beobachten zu können,
Und äh offensichtlich ist aber Facebook darüber hinaus noch der Meinung, dass sich eine Person des öffentlichen Interesses bin. Ja, du bist nur ein Interesse,
und dass ich, dass ich dann auch jetzt noch eine Etage drüber bin, das liegt wahrscheinlich dadran, dass du mit deinem Interesse hier abgebildet bist mit T-Shirt, wo drauf steht. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Also das ist einfach mich promotet hier.
Also im Zweifel würde ich sagen, lösen wir das einfach durch Likes.
Aber immerhin hier, wenn man äh unten auf verwandte Seiten, ja, dann äh sind interessante Querverweise zu sehen, unter anderem die digitale Gesellschaft und äh Hans-Christian Ströbele, das ist ja nun auch nicht die schlechteste.
Ja, aber das liegt wahrscheinlich wiederum daran, dass sie ähm den Wikipedia-Eintrag äh durchsuchen,
Also das ist einfach okay, wir wir schweifen auch ein bisschen ab. Also Facebook ähm Wikipedia und äh zuppelt die Sachen da rein und zumindest alle Personen. Und Hans-Christian Ströbele ist, glaube ich, auf der Wikipedia-Seite erwähnt und deswegen.
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall zum Heulen.
Es ist schon ähm ist schon ärgerlich, was man so als.
Als Kämpfer für die freie Information, ne, dann muss man solche muss man sich solche Ohrfeigen geben lassen. Na ja, vielleicht, ich frage mal den Max.
Welchen Max, den anderen Max. Ach so die.
Genau, aber der der wehrt sich natürlich dagegen. Das ist ein sorry. Ich sollte da vielleicht auch noch kurz, wenn ich jetzt diese ähm wenn ich jetzt gesagt habe, wie Facebook da eben gegen ihn argumentiert, ähm,
Er liegt eben Wert auf die Feststellung, dass er das eben aus einer aus einem Gerechtigkeitsempfinden macht und nicht aus einer äh aus einer Idee der persönlichen Bereicherung oder so. Und dass er damit auch kein.
Kein Geld verdient und äh ich glaube, selbst wenn, also das, das kann man ihm auch, glaube ich, sehr gut glauben, dass er damit jetzt nicht irgendwie reich wird, denn er hat ja auch einen Anwalt und der wird, der wird reich,
aber der ist halt auch kein Verbraucher. Er ist Anwalt. So.
Jetzt haben wir's aber.
Ja ähm kommen wir kommen wir nochmal zu Sigmar Gabriel,
muss ich nämlich auch nochmal ähm Feedback schon vor vor von der vorletzten Sendung äh anbringen,
denn da äh habe ich.
Betont, dass die das Sigma Gabriel einen plötzlichen Sinneswandel zur zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung gehabt hätte.
Und ähm dass er dem Verein,
D äh vierundsechzig da ins äh ins Kreuz treten würde mit diesem mit diesem Sinneswandel. Und da hat uns Andre kommentiert,
ich war auf dem D vierundsechzig Neujahrsempfang und auch dort hat Sigmar Gabriel die Vorratsdatenspeicherung verteidigt, wie es schon immer seine Position ist,
Nico Lümmer und Gabriel haben auch offen darüber debattiert in der ersten Reihe saß übrigens auch besagte Brigitte Zypries.
Und dann natürlich noch eine sehr wichtige äh Richtigstellung von Nico Lümmer, denn ich habe in der Sendung behauptet, er habe das äh Herz am rechten Fleck,
Das weißt er von sich. Er hat das Herz am linken Fleck.
Genau, das äh stellen wir dann hiermit auch fest.
So, aber kommen wir zurück zu zu Sigma Gabriel. Sigmar Gabriel hat ja jetzt was, was Herr ähm,
Sigmar Gabel ist ja jetzt gerade dabei, uns allen zu erklären, wie viel Unheil.
Von uns hätte abgewendet werden können, wenn ähm die wenn wir die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gehabt hätten.
Also Mario Sixtus twitterte dann schon äh wahrheitsgemäß, wenn wir in Vorzeitenspeicherung gehabt hätten, wäre Jesus nicht gekreuzigt worden, das fand ich einen schönen Ostertweet.
Der weiß,
Sigmar Gabriel, ähm wir haben das jetzt auch alles schon durch mit der Insel Utoya und was alles nicht schon hätte verhindert werden können und es wurde auch alles äh entkräftet und widerlegt. Und so richtig frech finde ich, dass er,
sich jetzt hingestellt hat und gesagt hat, naja, wir hatten ja dann auch noch den Nationalsozialistischen Untergrund, ne, die,
Mörderbande, die hier in Deutschland viele Jahre ungehindert ähm rassistische Morde,
ähm begangen hat. Und dann,
mussten die Angehörigen der Opfer noch über sich ergehen lassen, dass die äh Polizei und Ermittlungsbehörden überall
rumposaunt haben. Das ist ja hier nur Bandenkriminalität sein könne, weil das ja schließlich ähm,
äh Döner und Blumenhändler sind,
oder auch mal äh erfolgreiche Geschäftsleute und da wäre wahrscheinlich eine ganz heiße, werden sie auf einer ganz heißen Spur, dass was diese Gangster hier ähm austragen und das wird jetzt bald aufgeklärt
und ähm eine fremdenfeindlichen Hintergrund der Tat haben wir ja so lange ausgeschlossen, bis sich die drei ähm,
Haupttäter dann da irgendwann in dem Haus da in die Luft gesprengt haben.
Und das jetzt anzuführen ist natürlich wirklich ähm.
Wirklich frech, denn wie wäre dann in der Untersuchung dieses NSU ähm Skandals? Ähm.
Immer mehr festgestellt haben. Riecht das sehr an allen Ecken nach Verfassungsschutz, ja. Die haben in diesem Haus ähm,
legale, gefälschte Papiere gefunden, also üblicherweise das, was du von von,
dem Verfassungsschutz oder von der Polizeikriegs, wenn du eine gefälschte Identität annimmst, ja, dann dann fälschen die ja keinen Pass, sondern die gehen halt einfach hin und drucken ein.
Ähm es gab äh Observationsfotos,
kurz vor dem oder während der Zeit, wo die tätig waren, das heißt, der Verfassungsschutz wusste von denen war, hat die observiert, wusste, wo die sind und ähm,
hatten auch das Mobiltelefon von denen abgehört und die fast von dem äh Uwe Böhnhardt oder wie der heißt, äh Burnhart und ähm.
Die fast einhundert Verbindungen und aufgezeichneten Stunden langen Gespräche von diesem äh Mitglied der Mörderbande wurden
einen Tag nach Ende der Abhöraktion auf Anweisung der Staatsanwaltschaft Gera gelöscht. Also egal, wohin du da blickst, das riecht alles sowas von nach Verfassungsschutz, das waren alles voller V-Männer, die das ganze Ding irgendwie unterstützt haben,
Leute und jetzt sich auch noch hinzustellen und ausgerechnet ja so ein.
So ein Ding, was so von vorne bis hinten einfach nur nach Dreck stinkt, ja und wo von vorne bis hinten der Verfassungsschutz drinsteckt, irgendwie als ähm,
Als Beispiel zu nehmen, warum wir eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung brauchen, das erreicht echt ein Höhepunkt, den ich mir so gar nicht mehr hätte vorstellen können.
Erstaunlich, dass er da so drauf rumreitet, ne? Und irgendwie auch vollkommen,
also er auch immer weitere absurde Vergleiche macht. Kein kein Wunder, dass dann noch absurdere äh Vergleiche so im Scherzer herumgereicht werden, was sie noch alles hätte verhindert werden können mit der vor Ortsdatenspeicherung.
Und ähm wichtig, ne, am,
Also inzwischen Andre ist ja wirklich ein Goldstück in, in, in dieser, vor allem in der journalistischen Tätigkeit hier
der dann auf Netzpolitik orgab's einen sehr schönen, einen sehr schönen Artikel da dazu von Wetter, der eben auch sagt so, das ist ähm ist ja wohl eine eine.
Einfach nur unglaublich, dass nach diesem NSU-Skandal diese Behörde nicht beschnitten wird, sondern jetzt auch noch irgendwie eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung an die Hand gereicht bekommen soll.
Und ähm oder überhaupt die deutschen Ermittlungsbehörden, ja, Vorratsdatensprechung ist ja nicht nur für den Verfassungsschutz. Ähm und,
Andre hat da nur nochmal darauf hingewiesen, dass er ja schon im Oktober zweitausendzwölf,
darüber berichtet hat, dass bei den NSU-Ermittlungen Funkzellenabfragen gemacht wurden,
Aus denen am Ende zwanzig Millionen Verbindungsdaten vierzehntausend Namen und Adressen und nicht ein einziger Täter rausgefallen sind. Ähm was ja auch hier wieder sehr schön illustriert,
ähm.
Dass dass diese Datensammlung eben auch nichts bringen und erst recht nichts bringen, wenn deine Staatsanwaltschaft Gera,
ähm einen Tag nach Ende der Abhöraktion alles löschen lässt und der gesamte Nazi-Untergrund mit deinen eigenen V-Leuten unterwandert ist
ja? Und du am Ende ähm die ganze Sache nicht mehr hochgehen lassen kannst, weil du merkst, dass das deine eigene Abteilung ist. Ja, also das ist es wirklich
empfindlich, das nehme ich persönlich.
Also mit anderen Worten, man sieht hier nicht nur, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht äh nicht nur nicht geholfen hätte, sondern es gab sogar eine und sie hat äh auch keine Ergebnisse real gebracht,
also Vorratsdaten im Sinne von Funkzellenabfrage und ähm,
Das ist alles äh Quatsch und Augenwischerei und,
weist auch, also muss auch sagen, gerade was den NSU betrifft, das sieht alles so dermaßen auch nach Vereitlung aus an so vielen Stellen, dass ist nicht fein.
Den Wikipedia Artikel dazu mal zu lesen,
der Schlagkasse mit den Ohren und dieser Abschlussberichtes oder dieser diese Berichte aus dem NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss. Äh da also das ist, da kannst du, das,
Das geht auf gar keinen mehr. Das kannst du gar, kannst du gar nicht mehr erzählen,
so viel Wahnsinn, wie sich wie sich in diesem Ding verbirgt und man merkt, ich ich kann's selber noch nicht mal irgendwie äh zusammenfassen.
Ja, was machen wir jetzt mit Sigmar Gabriel?
Ja, keine Ahnung, können wir da irgendwie V-Leute hin entsenden, die den irgendwie.
Unschädlich machen oder so? Nee, ist Quatsch, ne? Wir müssen.
Nee, wir können da nichts mit V-Leuten machen. Das war jetzt, das war Unsinn. Ja, ich weiß nicht, was machen wir mit? Keine Ahnung, ist eines von vielen Problemen, die wir lösen müssen. Wer so einer von denen ähm ja, die wir irgendwie.
Ich fand ja den Gedanken sehr schön äh den den CDU mal mit dem Argument zu begegnen, äh mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ja, also wenn wir die Vorratsdatenspeicherung eingeführt oder ein,
schon eingeführt äh gehabt hätten, ja, dann wüssten wir ja heute auch die Spender von Helmut Kohl.
Da sollen sie mal drüber nachdenken.
Da bin ich. Das ist keine so blöde Idee.
Die wir bis heute noch noch nicht wissen, warum eigentlich, vielleicht brauchen wir da mal eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Deswegen.
Ja, weiß der Geier, welche Spender wir da dann und noch alles äh finden. Wahrscheinlich keine, weil das Instrumentarium äh versagt, aber der Gedanke ist natürlich sehr interessant.
Nun, lass uns weiterschreiten oder hattest du noch einen Punkt anzumerken.
Nee, nicht wirklich. Also es, es wird jetzt halt, vielleicht machen wir irgendwie ein running Gag draus, den den was, was Sigmar Gaure jetzt schon wieder
es gibt schon Running Gag, ja, genau, es das war dann, glaube ich, von extra drei angeleiert worden dieses ähm.
Einzusammeln, was es sonst noch so für Vorschläge gibt, wozu man die Vorratsdatenspeicherung verwenden könnte. Was alles hätte verhindert.
Genau, was was die Mauer, was die Mauerfall und was nicht alles, ne, das hätten wir alles hätte es alles mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht gegeben. Aber man fragt sich, woher der Mann diese diese.
Also das das frage ich mich wirklich und da habe ich jetzt, also es ist auch schön, dass wir darauf hingewiesen werden, dass er es schon länger so macht. Aber was ich wirklich nicht ich verstehe nicht, woher der diese.
Diese Energie nimmt, jetzt dieses Thema so voranzutreiben. Da gibt's ja einen Grund für.
Also, kann man vermuten, ne?
Ja. Naja, keine Ahnung. Danke, Sigmar Gabriel. Ist echt super, ist super, dass wir solche Opposition alwayd, ist ja gar keine Opposition. Mhm.
Ciao. So.
Nico einfach Recht und die wollen Kloppe.
Gut, äh lass uns zu deinem Lieblings äh Segment vorstoßen. Den Kurzmeldungen.
Ah, genau, ja.
Aber nicht so kurz, aber man kann sie ja zumindest mal so nennen.
Ja, wir müssen aber leider nicht erst recht. Ähm die die Drug and Forcement Agency, ähm die D E ähm.
D E ist, ist das, wo wo der Frank arbeitet bei Breaking Bad, ne? Oder habe ich das noch recht in Erinnerung?
Äh kann sein, ich habe das nicht gesehen.
Oh. Dann darf ich dir gratulieren, trotz deines hohen Alters. Hast du noch was im Leben vor dir, was dir richtig Freude bringen kann?
Ja, ich weiß. Aber äh ich gucke nicht so viel Fernsehen.
Machst bevor die das alle weghaken. Okay, also ähm,
Die die Drug and Force mit Agentsy hat seit neunzehnhundertzweiundneunzig,
bis zum September zweitausenddreizehn Metadaten gesammelt von internationalen Gesprächen von und Inländer, die sie nach eigenem Erkunden mit,
Drogenschmuggel in Verbindung gebracht hat. Zu Hochzeiten fielen darunter einhundertsechzehn Staaten.
Ja? Äh.
Die also zu dieser Sammlung der Verdächtigen gehörten, also fast sechzig Prozent aller Staaten, die es überhaupt weltweit gibt. Und diese Datensammlung der DEA ähm wurde natürlich, wie es mit Datensammlungen so ist,
für alle möglichen anderen Zwecke missbraucht. Ähm.
Und so wird ähm zitiert, dass ähm,
Anzahl an Datenanfragen, die die DIA an einem Tag bekommen hat, die ähm.
Die übertrifft die die Anzahl an Anfragen übertrifft, die die äh NSA in einem Jahr bekommen hat.
Und das ist natürlich, da kannst du dir jetzt anschauen was soll dir das jetzt bringen, ja?
Also was hat dieses Programm gebracht? Denn der Mangel an Rechtmäßigkeit des Programms, das war nämlich illegal, haben sie trotzdem einfach mal,
einundzwanzig Jahre lang gemacht,
führte dann dazu, dass Hinweise, die auf dessen Grundlage zustande gekommen sind, in den Verfahren nicht vorgebracht werden konnten.
Sondern als geheime Basis für offizielle Ermittlungen herhalten müssen
Das heißt, die Polizei oder andere äh Strafverfolgungsbehörden haben also dann bei der DEA angefragt, gib mal irgendwie die internationalen Verbindungen von Demo und dem. Und dann haben sie dadurch eben Anhaltspunkte gewonnen.
Und mussten sich dann aber noch ähm.
Ausreichende Beweismittel suchen, um einen Fall zu machen. Und ähm wir haben, glaube ich, schon öfter besprochen, warum das eben ein Problem ist, eine derartige Zusammenarbeit, beziehungsweise warum das.
Warum? Äh Moment, wie, also es gibt eine eine Trennung von Polizei und Geheimdiensten, Geheimdienste dürfen alles abhören,
Polizei darf nicht alles abhören, dafür darf der Geheimdienst sich nicht vor Gericht bringen. Polizei darf dich vors Gericht bringen. Und wenn die äh so zu einem wenn die so kooperieren, dann wird das eben mittelfristig ein ein großes Problem.
Weil du dann eben,
normalen Strafverfolgungsbehörden, die auch wirklich etwas gegen dich unternehmen können. Äh diese Instrumentarien an die Hand gibst. Na ja, aber wunderschön, dass die Polizei da über äh,
zwanzig Jahre mit solchen illegalen, nicht rechtmäßigen Methoden gearbeitet hat und,
Snowden ähm ähm zweitausenddreizehn an die Öffentlichkeit ging,
wurde das Programm dann ganz schnell beendet, weil sie gemerkt haben, OK, jetzt guckt hier mal einer drauf, was wir alles so machen.
Was war noch? Dann habe ich noch deinen Terminkalender gelesen.
Mein Terminkalender, aber der ist ja gar nicht, der ist doch gar nicht klassefrei.
Nicht? Du weißt, der steht sowieso schon im Internet.
Ich fand die Meldung eigentlich nicht so also nicht so spannend,
aber im im Rahmen der aktuellen Anstrengung von Obama, nämlich diesen nationalen Notstand gegen Hacker auszurufen, kam diese Meldung,
über ein Ereignis aus dem letzten Herbst ja dann doch sehr äh überraschend passend. Und zwar,
lautete sie, russische Hacker äh hätten also sich ins Weiße Haus eingehackt und hatten dann sogar Zugriff auf den nichtöffentlichen ähm Terminkalender von Barack Obama gehabt.
Sie hatten also zwar keinen Zugriff auf geheime Systeme, aber immerhin äh Zugang,
zu nichtöffentlichen Details, also den Terminplan und andere Teile der äh IT-Infrastruktur des Weißen Hauses erlangt.
Und ähm sie räumen sogar ein, dass derartiges Wissen natürlich für,
ausländische Geheimdienste sehr wertvoll ist.
Und sie sprechen von einer der ausgeklügelten Cyberattacken, die jemals gegen das weiße Haus ausgeführt worden seien. Ähm diese so ausgeklügelte,
Cyber-Attacke,
bestand dann im im Fishing über ein gekapertes E-Mail Konto. Ähm ist sowieso tatsächlich so, das siehst du bei den, bei den meisten Angriffen und ich es würde mich überraschen, wenn das bei äh,
TV am Ende nicht auch irgendwo noch eine Rolle spielt. Ähm,
das Phishing oder das sogenannte. Wo man also ähm,
Zielperson, Zielpersonen genau Auskunft schafftet, sich genau mit deren ähm Position im Unternehmen ähm vertraut macht und ihnen dann eine ähm,
E-Mails sendet und sie irgendwie täuscht und sie dazu bringt.
Daten preiszugeben oder Informationen preiszugeben. Der Klassiker ähm ist zum Beispiel du schickst etwas, was aussieht wie eine,
Passwort, E-Mail und,
da drin befindet sich dann ein Link zu einer gefälschten Seite und in diese gibt das Opfer dann eben seine,
Für die jeweilige Seite ein. Also was weiß ich, sei es E-Mail, sei es äh Facebook oder sonst was. Ähm
und dann geben sie, geben sie dir dadurch die Credentials und dann hast du schon mal dann deren E-Mail-Konto übernommen und dann kannst du natürlich anfangen, von deren E-Mail-Konto.
Weitere E-Mails an andere Personen zu schreiben,
in deren Vertrauenskreis sind und den Vertrauenskreis kriegst du ja, weil in dem E-Mail-Konto ja alle E-Mails sowieso schon mal gespeichert sind,
Das heißt, wenn du einmal, wenn du einmal wirklich so in einem Unternehmen ein E-Mail Konto übernommen hast, äh oder Unternehmen oder ähm jetzt hier in so einer Organisation oder was, dann kannst du, wenn du dir damit Zeit und Ruhe lässt,
am Ende schon 'ne Menge infiltrieren. Du nimmst dir natürlich dann auch nicht irgendjemanden,
sondern du nimmst natürlich Leute, die irgendwie an der Spitze der Hierarchie stehen und ähm arbeitest dich dann so aus deren,
aus deren System irgendwie weiter, gibt's Anweisungen, vielleicht mal bestimmte Passwörter zu ändern, fragst mal nach irgendeiner Information,
oder in ne, sorgst dafür, dass du dann vielleicht doch noch ein ein System übernimmst, aber das ist eigentlich etwas, was man in letzter Zeit,
tatsächlich seltener sieht bei so großen Angriffen. Das heißt, sie gehen, die Angreifer versuchen so viel wie möglich über Fishing zu machen, weil die.
Ähm die Infrastruktur, die jetzt irgendwie so die IT-Sicherheitsinfrastruktur offenbar momentan ähm,
eine so große Hürde darstellt, beziehungsweise weil auch in den letzten Jahren immer mehr in,
Detection und Monitoring ähm investiert wurde, sodass die Gefahr erkannt zu werden
Wenn man also wirklich einen Angriff macht und einen Explode zum Einsatz bringt, eben relativ groß ist und man gleichzeitig sehr viel einfacher und sehr viel schöner durch solche Phishing und,
Sozial Engineering Sachen zum Ziel kommt. Und ja, das ist natürlich jetzt auch den den USA geschehen. Ähm.
Ich denke mal, dass äh das nicht das erste Mal gewesen sein wird und ich kritisiere,
den Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung insbesondere dann auch noch die Atribation auf auf russische,
und ähm also so in in dieser Zeit, wo irgendwie die die Verhältnis das Verhältnis zu Russland zerrüttet ist und man noch irgend so einen Cyber-Notstand ausrufen will,
dann irgendwie mit einer Meldung vom vom vom letzten Quartal auf einmal um die Ecke zu kommen. Das riecht doch dann schon sehr nach irgendwie.
Spin. Riecht nach Spin.
Das ich das bin.
Trotzdem ist die Meldung, bin ich mir relativ sicher, wahr und es würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn sie nicht vielleicht doch dann in äh sichere, sicherere Systeme oder.
Schützenswertere Systeme erlangt haben als jetzt nur den nichtöffentlichen Terminkalender des Präsidenten. Wen würde der schon interessieren, ja?
Naja, der ist äh natürlich schon sehr wertvoll.
Also ich hätte meinen also der ich gehe mal davon aus, dass der IT-Sicherheitsbeauftragte des Weißen Hauses ähm,
oder wer auch immer dafür verantwortlich ist, den Terminkalender des US-Präsidenten nicht als äh besonders schützenswert zu kategorisieren. Inzwischen ähm irgendwie wahrscheinlich.
In die Privatwirtschaft gewechselt ist, wie man so schön sagt.
Genau, wurde weitergereicht. Ja. Wollen wir dann auch in die Privatwirtschaft äh wechseln? So.
Ich habe, glaube ich, genug Wirtschaftsfreude.
Ja. Ja, ich meinte ja auch die andere Wirtschaft.
Die Schadenwirtschaft.
Kreuzberger Nichte sind lang irgendwie.
Ja, da müssen wir mal gucken.
Gut, ähm ja, wir haben ja wieder äh massive Zeitunterschiede hier, die muss Rechnung getragen werden, du musst ins Bett, ne, genau. Auch äh bei mir.
Nichts für, wenn du auf einmal irgendwie da auf auf so eine einsame Insel ziehst.
Ja, ich kann auch nichts dafür, wenn du auf einmal da im im im Osten abtauchst, dann geht die Sonne halt früher auf.
Im Westen.
Wie auch immer.
So, wir müssen.
Ein Ende finden.
Wir müssen ein Ende finden und wir tun das jetzt auch und äh wie gesagt, ach so, genau, ich hab's ja eigentlich gerade schon so halbwegs angedeutet. Es werden dann am am Freitag, den siebzehnten,
in Bielefeld die Big Brother Awards verliehen. Da ähm werde ich dann auch zu Gast sein und der Max Shrimps. Und das ist in an einem geheimen Ort,
mit dem Namen Bielefeld.
Wohin sie mich da verschleppen.
Du bist da, okay, aber du musst keine äh musst keine Rede halten oder so.
Doch, muss ich bin dazu verdonnert worden. Ich muss.
Okay, aber du sagst auch nicht für wen?
Das ist geheim. Das ist Geheimtipp.
Das ist geheim, ne? Gut, da bin ich ja dann mal gespannt. Da werden wir dann äh nächste Woche von berichten oder? Übernächste Woche? Nächste Woche.
Ja, nee, übernächste Woche, das ist ein Freitag, der siebzehnte. Und genau und an, und an den darauffolgenden Montag, den zwanzigsten,
ähm können dann die Logbuchnetzpolitik Hooligans äh sich im Innenausschuss des Deutschen Bundestages mit Bengalo positionieren.
LLP Ultras. Ja.
Nein, bitte, bitte keine Bengalus im im Innenausschuss.
Ja, das könnte könnte sich negativ auswirken, da müssen wir wieder Vertragsstrafe zahlen oder sowas.
Da kriegt man auch nichts rein in den in den Bundestag. Ich nehme da ja jedes Mal, ich versuche ja immer noch was was mitzunehmen, ne? Aber.
Kriegt nicht.
Flasche weg.
Sowas. Gut, ich äh bin auch durch. Linus, wir sagen tschüss, bis bald.
Bis denn, ciao, ciao.